[Music]
a congrats are in order Chrissy Teigen
and John Legend are expecting this is
like obviously such an incredibly
important event Chrissy Instagram the
happy news sharing these positively
glowing baby bump pics in writing quote
we have another on the way if you've
been enough time together you never know
the couple's already parents the
six-year-old daughter Luna and
four-year-old son miles I know it sounds
silly if you don't have kids but they
say mama dad all the time but it's weird
when they know that you're the mama and
you're the daddy and you're that it's
it's just different and this will be a
rainbow baby for Chrissy and John they
lost their third child a son jack in
2020. something Chrissy reflected on in
her new post quote the last few years
have been a blur of emotions to say the
least but joy has filled our home and
hearts again everything is good I
finished my my IVF part so I feel so
much healthier and so much better with
that earlier this year Chrissy let fans
in on her IVF journey and now months
later a bundle of joy on the way she
admits quote I don't think I'll ever
walk out of an appointment with more
excitement than nerves but so far
everything is perfect and beautiful and
I'm feeling hopeful and amazing the news
comes shortly after Christy hit a major
Milestone celebrating one year of
sobriety from alcohol I also connected
with those feelings of like immense
regret or like stupid moments but yeah
the the sobriety thing is fun yeah Mal's
and Luna are pretty lucky to have
Chrissy and John for parents but as
Chrissy recently explained these are two
other celebs the kids are even more
obsessed with Miles was like growing out
with your childhood Crush Lance Bass who
knew is he ready to be in a boy band now
I made oh he has no idea like how cool
these people are too it's so um he's
been in love with lands for years now
and I mean he's only four so it was two
years ago that he saw him last but he
really connected with him two years ago
too I have like all this old footage of
him hanging all over him and they're
just not like this with anybody oh my
God whatever he's learned a celebrity
crush Luna loves Whitney Cummings so
funny who doesn't who doesn't right he
is so like sweet and she's like
childlike it herself so like they play
with makeup together and they have
something and they're interested is the
same it's like horseback riding and
makeup
foreign
[Music]